[Applause]  can't hit the three  rebound  oh a touchdown pass  middleton  aaron rodgers-esque that was a great  pass  giannis catches it right in stride and  goes in for the dump  and one  hot start for the bucks  scoring inside and in transition  [Applause]  claxton setting the screen griffin nice  swing  adenocambol comes claxton at the rim  this is a great pass by blake griffin  but giannis on the rotation  a great block  this is where giannis is at his best  defensively is when he's off the ball  and coming as a help defender  12-0 run  and agumpo tries to get around durant  somehow gets it to go and the  foul he anticipated a foul from lopez  euro  oh some english on it  so so difficult to defend  in transition  and you look up here  grayson allen can't answer rebound on  a one-man wrecking crew  mills has middleton they switch again  [Applause]  31 points 13 rebounds six assists